so this afternoon we have a great treat
we're going to be joined by president
salivate this is our third year of the
day of data and each year we've strived
to get a senior administrator to come
and talk to us and this year we struck
at bank we got the university president
he has miss pushed aside the Provost
this year and but that was okay with it
and then we'll be hearing from
presidents olive a he adds a long career
here at Yale where he started as a
graduate student there was a professor
of psychology and through all that work
himself has worked with data a lot so
this is both important to Yale as a
whole but also to his own personal
research so let me introduce President
Salva well thank you very much Susan and
welcome everybody you know I just want
to say something about susan when when
we hired University Librarian few years
back we were looking someone who for
someone who would interpret what it
means to be the university librarian in
the broadest possible way and you know
not just a custodian of book collections
but a kind of recognition that that the
contemporary university librarian is
someone who really facilitates research
scholarship been teaching by essentially
making resources of all kinds that can
be archived collected organized
interpreted available to them and susan
has interpreted that charge that mission
that job description as broadly as
anyone on this campus and we are very
very fortunate to have her in that role
and it's wonderful have someone who
respects the old and the traditional and
loves books but also is not afraid to
embrace and rush toward the new
the entire the technological end of all
of this and she does both she does both
very very well if you've now if you
really haven't ever gotten to know her
you should take a minute and introduce
yourselves and find out find out what's
going on in our library system so it's a
pleasure to be here this is the third
year of an outstanding program that has
proven quite popular on this campus I
think it is a testimonial to both what
libraries do and what librarians do but
it also helps to galvanize a kind of
collective interest in the use of data
in research and data management as well
throughout the campus what I love about
the theme is it's so cross-cutting and
so interdisciplinary so as you heard on
a psychologist I work in a data
intensive field most of our data are
either gathered in experiments or in big
field studies or sometimes in survey
research and sometimes use of archival
sources mostly quantitative and that's
only just a little you know tip of the
iceberg of what what is possible but
very dependent as a psychologist both on
what capacities the university had to
manage data make it available but also
data analysis interpretation and what I
love about this theme the day of data
theme is it really cuts across
disciplines like my own and sort of says
what are our common ways of managing
planning using interpreting data I think
many of you know when I became president
two years ago I talked a lot about a
more unified yell and in fact the theme
of our the inauguration which was two
years ago next month was going to be one
yell and a couple of weeks before we
announced that that before we were going
to announce the theme one yell
Harvard announced their fundraising
campaign one Harvard and so we realized
that we had to do one yell implicitly
and so you may have remembered posters
and tote bags and things that that would
say many disciplines many people many
nationalities many departments many this
many that many this many that Yale right
it was one yet it was the implicit one
yield well you know when it comes to
thinking about data numerical
geographical textual visual you know I
think we are one Yale I think we can
take a kind of a unified approach to
management organization accessibility
consultation all the all the tools and
assistance that anyone in this room and
Beyond might need and as a result do it
in a way that makes this among the
easier places to actually get work done
you know there are you just have to look
around a little bit university
initiatives of the last year to see the
ways in which research data can be used
to address complicated needs of this
place so you know the opening its now
make a telecon was yesterday it wasn't
yesterday but the opening of the center
for science and social science
information which created three years
ago explicitly to support data
management and analysis in what had
originally been a wonderful home for
largely biology books the yale center
for research computing which is
supporting advanced computing data
processing processing technology makes
its resources available throughout the
research community the university
libraries interdisciplinary digital
humanities Lab provides expertise
equipment facilities to faculty and
students often in fields who didn't
think about the of themselves as data
intensive fields but now discover what
they can
do with data there's a data policy
committee appointed by the provost and
charged with developing guidelines for
acquisition management storage and
they're going to release their
recommendations later this semester so
I'm hoping that the day of data which my
guess is the day of data has something
in it for everyone I hope it stimulates
you to think about new ideas new
approaches to information new
opportunities maybe new supports and
services that Yale provides that you
didn't know about if that happens that
would be a great thing because we want
nothing more than the ability to for you
to produce world-class scholarship and
research and then to teach to provide
them the best teaching I would say the
most excellent teaching but that sounds
like what are those characters who have
the excellent adventure bill and ted
bill and ted it sounds like Bill and Ted
when I say and provide the most
excellent education in a research
university environment this is part of
how we how we do that I don't want to
take more time but because it does give
me great pleasure to introduce our
keynote speaker today this is chaton
baru he's from the University of
California San Diego he currently serves
as the National Science Foundation
senior advisor for data science in that
role at NSF he supports collaborative
efforts pertaining to big data and he's
going to speak today on the topic of
data science or indie current activities
and future directions so let me ask you
to join me in welcoming schatten baru
with a very warm round of applause
all right just a second as I get this
fired up
there we go
but well thanks very much for that
introduction and actually thanks to the
organizers for inviting me here to give
the stock it's real pleasure I what I've
what I've heard so far in the session in
the morning I think there's a lot of
excitement across campus in the area of
data this is your third year to do this
my sense is each year this has been
building up it must be because it
there's so much going on right now that
I can see so it's this is my first
actually visit to Yale in this capacity
I think I've been here once maybe 15
years ago as a tourist just touring New
England happened to go through new haven
but I took the train up from Washington
DC is actually very nice train ride you
see some scenic spots along the way so
very happy to be here I think my task in
this next hour using the clock that
actually works the as Bob found out is a
not to put you to sleep right after a
nice panera sandwich and be to just give
you a sort of on let's say 25 to 30,000
foot level view of the variety of data
science big data activities that are
going on mostly at NSF and i'll also say
a little bit about some of the
interagency things so hopefully you get
a sense of the landscape of things that
are happening needless to say this is a
really exciting area exciting times for
data we'll get into some of these during
my presentation as everyone says there
is nothing new about data especially
scientists will say that's what we've
been doing all along so we will touch a
little bit upon what makes it new and
different now the reason I actually
decided to sort of leave San Diego and
go to Washington DC and take this is
this is actually a new position at NSF a
senior advisor for data science and I
thought this is really interesting time
to be there both to help NSF think to do
some of these plans and do some of those
interagency things so all right so let's
get started
so I predicted I was purposely used data
science R&D in my topic in my title it
doesn't say big data and I now I'll come
to that the presentation will primarily
be of course from the point of view of
NSF so NSS perspective and role in the
federal government is you know it's the
agency that supports basic
curiosity-driven research and these are
the words from the actual mission of NSF
to promote the progress of science to
advance the national health prosperity
and welfare to secure the National
Defense actually after i went to NSF i
read one ever Bush's original report
that put NSF together and in fact what
is now called NIH all was in one
organization and then things split later
on so let's get into the topic right
away so this whole phenomena of big data
which I don't have to define you already
heard that from Bob this morning I think
fundamentally what it has done why are
things different now considering that
scientists have always dealt with data
is it's just the amount of data and the
our ability to so easily collect so many
different types of data for any problem
that we are looking at has essentially
forced on us a greater awareness of of
data so we just need to it's no longer
taking some data set that somebody or
you collected or somebody else in fact
primarily that you collected and did
something with it increasingly there are
data sets that others have collected
increasingly their requirements some of
which might come from the federal
government let's say you have to make
these data available for a long term and
so you start worrying about what does
that mean metadata context
sustainability etcetera so the way I
would say it is they're just greater
awareness of all aspects of data it's
and this goes by the way not just in
science but in business as you know the
term really sort of got developed by
folks in business and strata Hadoop
conference is later this month thing Bob
mentioned it I'm actually applying to
attend I hope some of you will be there
it's really totally energetic and
exciting place to be
if you just want to see the extent of
stuff that's happening in industry
strata Hadoop conference is a good place
to be so whether it's an industry or in
science we sort of thought about
traditionally it's been about just
looking at cleaned up structured data
and doing the analytics now we realize
that as we get not just designed data
but what is called found data so not
just data that you created but later
that others have put together and you're
using it in in some way in your analysis
you realize that you are worried about
the entire lifecycle of data you have to
have much more awareness of you know
what is the context in which this data
was collected what is the context in
which I'm reusing it it's all types of
data it's unstructured semi-structured
we heard about text analysis this
morning there's all sorts of image data
that we collect this maps special
temporal all of that and as context
becomes important and reuse becomes
important it's as much about the
metadata so that there is some
understanding of what this original data
set was as it is about the data itself
and at the end of the day all of this
has to be processed efficiently and used
so if you collect data and you never use
it it's like not collecting data at all
right so and also if you look at it in
business and increasingly in some of the
sciences that are collecting lots of
data actually astronomy comes to mind
but increasingly i would think things
like genomics etc there is this issue of
timely use so i think we are pushing
more and more and more towards real-time
online analysis of data if you think of
it that's actually one way by which you
can avoid collecting a whole lot of data
if you can just process it in time and
make use of it or not and chuck it or
maybe just keep a representation of it
so essentially as was mentioned I'm
originally from University of California
in San Diego i'm at the supercomputer
center but my background is as a
computer scientist i'm in the field
called database systems so for if you
are in the data field these are
absolutely exciting times because all
the stuff that you did 10 15 years ago
it's all coming back
and even more important way so it is
definitely rejuvenated and created a new
research agenda around data actually
there was a question I wanted to ask so
let me do it now so one of those
strategies to make sure that you're not
totally asleep so let's see how many
folks in the audience are faculty
members okay that's good there are some
but there's lots of non-faculty so i
assume lot of them are grad students
maybe summer stuff how many in the
audience are computer scientists right
so I think there needs to be more
computer scientists in the room but but
that's that's one of the things I will
talk about data science in fact here it
is so if you look at NSF the kinds of
things that NSF funds this stretch the
whole range from basic research on one
side and infrastructure on the other
side now the infrastructure that NSF
funds of course is in support of basic
research so usually its instruments of
some type you know regardless of which
Directorate you are in whether it's
geosciences or astronomy or ecology etc
these are all about building
state-of-the-art instruments that can
collect more data and of course that's
what they are all doing NSF has programs
across the spectrum basic research as
well as applied areas there are programs
for for example creating software that
could be used by a discipline and may be
reused by others there are programs for
networking there are programs for
actually having supercomputers and
storage and so on and and there are big
programs in in many of the directorate's
I don't think and size particularly
computer science particularly doesn't
have any but many of the other
directorates have programs for data
archives these are community scientific
data archives icpsr was mentioned and
there are many others so and there is of
course a division at at NSF called the
ACI which is part of size that funds
things on the infrastructure side and
education and training is also a big
part of all of this right so on this
education and train
both on the basic side and the
infrastructure side that is there are
programs all the way from doing research
in education to supporting graduate
education the nrt program that's there
which used to be the Eiger but there are
also programs more on the training side
so if your scientists you want to use
some computational resources and hope
increasingly I hope there are also such
things for data resources then there are
programs that allow for training in that
area so this whole field of big data and
now introduce the data science sits
across all of that there are activities
at NSF that are in that box or that
circle that cut across from basic
research to infrastructure to education
and training and say a little bit about
that so what is this term then data
science and actually it's in the title
of the position I have the senior
advisor for data science and one way I
like to think about it and maybe it's
partly because I'm also from a
supercomputer center is you know big big
data is to data science as
supercomputing was to computational
science in other words I think there was
a reference earlier to you know more is
something different right so when you
have more of something significantly
more of something you really enter a new
state and that's basically what super
super computing did when you had that
scale of computing available you had all
sorts of new computational methods in
all sorts of disciplines oh so not just
physics and astronomy it's it's
everything all the way down to social
sciences now and certainly ecology and
all of those areas looking at
computational techniques so to the
extent that we said okay that that's a
discipline in which some training needs
to be given and there are men there are
several at least graduate student
programs and computational science that
get you trained in how to do it how to
model things are using computational
science and then how to do them at scale
this term wasn't mentioned today but you
may have heard of this notion of the
fourth paradigm right so the third
paradigm is computing the fourth
paradigm is data so computational
science
the third paradigm I think what big data
has done that is the availability of so
much data of so many different kinds
that could be used in so many different
contexts is created the need as i said
earlier to understand the full lifecycle
of data to get a much more in-depth
training on all of those aspects of data
and not just sort of stay on the edges
of it and i think that basically leads
to creation of data science as an
endeavor in itself so i'll say a lot
maybe quite a bit more later on about
various activities that we are
supporting and the community is doing in
pushing forward the data science agenda
but actually a lot of what i heard this
morning of the yale institute for
network science is an interesting one
there are so many common problems with
data there are seen across so many
different disciplines that that itself
becomes something to be studied and we
also heard that Yoon sung like the law
school they were like their students to
receive at least some training in data
so there's also this notion that if you
had a core body of knowledge that
information could be imparted to specify
specific specialized courses to
different other departments and domain
so I think what is emerging here is this
notion of data science and that's why I
title my talk is data science R&D if you
zoom into computer science as
Directorate at NSF we certainly found
things on the foundational research side
and the other directorates at NSF V
computer scientists think of them as the
domains right those are the guys who
have some problems that maybe we can
help help them solve it the big data
program at size in in size at NSF is
really the one that connects the two so
a big data as if you think in terms of
proposals a successful Big Data proposal
is one that really bridges these two in
an effective way it's looking at new
fundamental techniques maybe it's
scaling maybe it's a new algorithm with
a real problem that needs to be solved
in the domain science orange
getting discipline so one of the things
I do in my other life so if you are at
some of you may have been at NSF but if
you read NSF there is this notion of ird
you can do your independent R&D you get
some time to do that and one of the
things I do it during my independent R&D
activities back in San Diego is related
to benchmarking of big data applications
and we run a workshop every year and the
next one is in December in India and one
of the speakers there once who is from
Facebook came and said in a big data to
us means big right so here at face
Facebook the notion of big data is just
big stuff there's petabytes of data
Facebook has something like twenty
thirty thousand instances of my sequel
database basis because every data
scientist so that Facebook basically
goes to work every day pulls out some
data from that big well of petabytes of
data creates their own little database
and they're trying to trying the next ad
placement algorithm or whatever it is
right so there are some people for whom
big data just means big but what I like
to say is big data is also about data
and the data comes from discipline so if
you're a computer scientist looking at
this there are increased increasingly
areas in computer science that that are
sort of data intensive network
engineering is one there are groups that
have collected lots of internet traffic
data but by and large at least so far
computer science has not been a data
intensive field but what computer
science has done is worked with data
that may come from all sorts of other
disciplines and I'm talking in terms of
doing its own field doing its own
research so data has to come from
domains and therefore if you are doing
big data research as a computer
scientist you need to be very intimately
tied to the domains there are certainly
examples of big science data I won't go
into all the details of this well just
give you a laundry list of names many of
these many of you would have heard of
ligo is
physics observatory generating about a
petabyte of data per year LHC Large
Hadron Collider you're all heard about
at Sun is collecting for petabytes per
year LS STS is the newest NSF big
instrument project that just got
inaugurated down in Chile I mean the
construction has just started and that's
going to generate 100 petabytes in 10
years it's going to at the end of the
day it will have a ten petabyte catalog
database so it's just the catalog of
stuff that's in the sky and so that's 10
petabytes so actually the structured
data okay of course n car is a NSF
funded center who they do a lot of
observational data and they also do
simulations they have a new
supercomputer that's able to do bigger
and bigger simulations and generate more
and more data there are a couple of
other observational projects at NSF one
is Earth scope in the geosciences that's
essentially trying to do a 4d snapshot
of the lithospheric structure of
continental US so they have seismograms
and other instruments they sort of their
swept across the continent and collected
all this data and there's the ocean
observing initiative collecting data
from ocean sites okay there are other
new things coming along the way you
might have heard about this interest in
something called the materials genome
initiative which is more in the
chemistry and material sciences one of
the that that's a very nascent area in
fact that community is trying to figure
out what their data challenges really
are going to be and one of the things
that they encounter is a heterogeneity
of data right now the amounts of data
may not be large but they collect all
sorts of different kinds of data and the
idea here is to see what you can do by
data collection to speed up the
materials discovery and smart man
eventually leading to things like smart
manufacturing and so on all of these
projects as I mentioned before our
instrumentation project
they get funded through these special
mechanisms that NSF has for allocating
large one time allocation of large
chunks of money that go towards building
these things so these are called the MRE
FC major research equipment and facility
construction awards usually in the few
hundred million dollar range but i think
this term was also mentioned today
somebody talked about data scope maybe
it was Bob I can't remember now data in
some sense is the new instrument so if I
have a lot of data available to me like
this data scientist at Facebook who goes
to work every day and the petabytes of
stuff that we are doing in terms of
click streams and image images that we
loaded up in facebook that's their data
what are the increasingly want to go to
a mode of operation we're just analyzing
that data is the work that you do so the
collection is not as much on the
collection side it's more on the
analysis side I'm going to come back and
talk about that axe actually as one of
our challenges how do we how do we make
sure that as a community we actually
have access to more and more data that's
growing to be a bit of a challenge this
is very quick I think some of you would
be very familiar i mean the Keck
Observatory is I think jointly run by
Yale which is up in Mauna Kea and I was
at the vldb conference I don't know if
any of you had gone day which was couple
of weeks ago on the Big Island and
actually went to Mauna Kea first time in
my life and and and saw some of these
basically what the these communities are
facing that increasingly all of the rest
of science is facing is the ability to
easily collect data which is much more
than all the data you had so far in the
history of the field right so in the
case of astronomy within a decade over
140 terabytes of information was
collected so far before Sloan Digital
Sky Survey which is already a decade or
more old and within the first few weeks
the Sloan's survey over to bat LSST will
in the first 10 days or so
what Sloane collected okay so huge rates
at which this data are being generated
now if you step back and think in terms
of where we are in all of this as an R&D
discipline or are in the activity at the
bottom what I've tried to show with my
funky little diagram is you know so far
what we've been looking at in the data
area is building data acquisition
systems that can collect lots of data
building data repositories that can
serve community datasets perhaps
developing knowledge structures ontology
zor semantics of the information so that
there can be properly use and use of the
data ideas like the data Commons so that
data can be shared so you can think of
all of those as sort of the
infrastructure that's around data and a
lot of what we have done so far is in
that area the research programs that NSF
is funding right now in fact our big
data program is actually called critical
techniques and technologies for big data
I think are the next level up which is
okay you already have these building
blocks how do you now build systems that
allow you to make use of data in a much
more facile and easy way or maybe
develop new algorithms on the data that
you have and some of this speaks to this
idea of the human data science interface
and I think again Bob mentioned that so
you could either the horizontal bar
meaning that you could build
technologies that take existing pieces
and put them together and make them much
more usable maybe you build workflows
etc the vertical piece meaning that we
might be inventing new ways of doing
things that we may have to go back and
change some of what's going on in the
technologies so Hadoop was mentioned
earlier so if you look at something like
a Duke people are in a very engineering
Hadoop to make it much more online so
when Hadoop first started off it was
kind of more of a batch oriented
processing paradigm but people want to
process these huge amounts of data using
more of an online
paradigm so maybe we have to go and
re-engineer some of those things so
that's the kind of idea so I think of
what's down below and what we have done
so far as the first generation of big
data and I think where we need to be
heading is the second generation which
is actually the use of the data for
useful things whether it's in science or
societal applications or business
applications so it's the application of
this data towards some objective is
really the target so what are the
challenges in doing this how do you
promote and incentivize
interdisciplinary research I think just
like you folks are doing here I think
all i don't know if i can say all but
many campuses are facing this issue how
do you how do you bring folks together
on campus if you really think about it
people's lives on campuses also hurdle
at you know light speed everybody has
stuff to do they have to publish the
next paper graduate their next tour and
teach their next class and then we are
asking them to do this interdisciplinary
thing so there's a challenge here and
how do you incentivize that is one of
the challenges one way we think would be
through research programs that require
you to interact right another challenge
as I mentioned and I will be coming back
to this theme is how do we make how do
we provide access to researchers to
interesting and real data I think that's
a real challenge it's it said the crux
of breaking some of these bottlenecks
and getting more interesting result sort
of data again if you think in terms of
generation one in generation to that i
just showed we are still sort of in the
generation one where we are collecting
lots of data we'd like to move to
generation to where the data is
available and what you should really be
doing is using your smarts to analyze
the data and do something interesting
with it so how do we get there is a
challenge another challenge I see is how
do we provide the platforms and this is
I'm talking about in academia that allow
you to do data science research in the
plan i say platform i mean the hardware
the software and the data they are all
part of the platform there are different
parts of the research community that
might just want
big hardware platform so maybe they can
develop the next Hadoop or next
something right there are others who
want to use the available software to do
some analysis one of the things I've
heard from the community certainly is
the data science database type community
is a lot of papers are published about
results you know how good how fast
something runs and there are many such
papers every paper uses its own system
and these papers are really at some
level not comparable because they are
all running on different Hardware doing
their own essentially assumptions right
and so if you really start getting
bothered by that then you say well could
we create some kind of a platform on
which we can have comparable results and
finally there are the last one which is
right now at least to me seems the Holy
Grail is there are researchers of you at
least we would like them to just work
with the data so i give you the platform
I you all the software what I want you
to do is do something interesting with
the data and this could either be
generating new algorithms or coming up
with new and maybe new science or new
ways of making decisions with the data
so all three are part of the platform
the reason this is a challenge is you
must you may have heard of this and
people are now calling this the brain
drain right I have been in discussions
where there's a concern of the brain
drain that is researchers leaving
academia to essentially go to Google and
Microsoft and Facebook because that's
why are they doing it because that's
where the data is so if you really want
to do interesting stuff with real data
people are moving off to those places
suddenly annoyed UC San Diego we've lost
several of our colleagues want to Google
12 amazon 12 microsoft and if you're a
systems person that's where the big
platforms are so i think this is
something we need to address and how do
we do this so maybe this is my chance to
do the soap box on this one you know a
few decades ago the thing that
universities couldn't get their hands on
was a supercomputer no single university
could buy a supercomputer like a cray
the one that Bob showed in this slides
right the circular thing
so therefore there was a national
program that said gee we were to buy
these things and make them available to
the community today what no single
University can buy is a cluster that
Google could have right 100,000 not
cluster so how do you facilitate that so
this is AB certainly started talking
with folks in the community who are very
interested in you know at least thinking
about how to go about this problem so
maybe some of you will pick up on that
education and development of a new
pedagogy in data science and I'll come
back and talk about that so data science
it becomes a thing unto itself and so
how do we develop education programs and
what are the principles of data science
as distinct from computer science on one
side and statistics on the other side
sustainability of resources another big
problem so those of you who are running
campus resources you know that you know
we have data management plans but how do
you keep this going reproducibility of
research is another big issue and I was
mentioning to someone we just had the
director of NSF just had a seminar a
couple of days ago a one day workshop on
this issue of reproducibility and i
think it's it's a big big deal if we can
certainly get into discussions i won't
say anything more about that and i also
meant already mentioned the brain drain
issue so let's see i'm trying to see how
I can liven this up well so I guess I
just have to go through it so let me I
was going to give you this is the 30,000
foot level thing I was talking about so
if you think in terms of the investments
that NSF does and actually this would
apply to any federal agency that's doing
R&D investments this is a reasonable
quadrant diagram that we all have
started using to describe that so on one
box you have foundational research on
the other side you have cyber
infrastructure the facilities there's
education and training and then there is
in a way it's sort of which we call
community building and
and the reason that's important in big
data is again because of what we said
before it's this is a field where we are
trying to connect technologies and I
don't mean just computer science it's
statistics math CS all of those with end
applications real applications and that
requires formation forming
collaborations it also requires
collaborations that are not just among
academic institutions but what we call
multi-sector so academia industry and
government and its government at all
levels local state federal so that's an
important part of trying to accelerate
sort of the whole ecosystem and in the
middle sits policy again somebody
mentioned the data policy I think maybe
in your talk NSF has put out a data
policy and so these are all things that
govern all of this so quickly in
foundational research big data is a
program out of NSF we just announced the
awards I have some numbers later on I
think we've hundred thirty thirty
proposals this year in big data it's a
cross-cutting initiative it involves all
directorates at NSF it also involves an
agency called the Office of Financial
Research I might have something later on
that but we're far is a set was set up
through the Department of Treasury and
their task is essentially to build a
model of the financial system of the
country so that they can try to do some
predictive models of how where the
financial system is going they have
access to very interesting data and they
also have access to extremely fine
grained financial data that is
confidential but researchers can get
access to it in the NDA sort of way so
it's sort of like working with census
data if you're a demographic you can get
micro date out of census but there are
some rules and regulations so we're far
is the same we also have a program
called CD s any computational and data
science and engineering the distinction
between these two is in big data we are
really looking for some and
edge that makes it new and different
because of the big phenomena again it's
all those v's that you saw in the slide
you know we have lots of data scaling is
an issue of have lots of data may be
simpler models work better than more
complex models or actually complex
models won't work because they're just
too computationally intensive maybe you
have variety of data so a lot of
heterogeneity in the data maybe its
semantic heterogeneity or some other
format heterogeneous so it has to be
something in the Big Data solicitation
where it's pushing a new aspect of data
whereas in CDA sandy the focus is more
on you're pushing a new science you may
you may be using standard siggraph
method that we saw earlier it's just you
know there may be some complexity in the
graph as to what the nodes mean and what
the links mean but what you're really
pushing is the science that comes out of
it so that's sort of the distinction
between the two and we also have some
special programs big data for disasters
was a program that was done with Japan
there's one called future cloud which is
sort of a large-scale platform but it's
much more focused on really sort of
operating systems and network research
and not so much on the data research
itself and in future Claude has been
awarded I think there are two platforms
in the country that which I meant to be
community resources cyber infrastructure
I think you know about this the ACI was
mentioned before there is CCD and I I
think i heard yale must you got one of
these 100 gigabit the awards to connect
the campus so these are for high speed
networking building data resources and n
for hpc platforms i mentioned NRP on the
education side and i will come back to
tell you a little bit more of what we
are doing on education and one of the
things that we have started for the
community building is this new in a
program called big data regional
innovation hubs those awards were just
recently made i believe and there are
four and I'll say more about it so let
me quite keep quiet for now and all of
this is in the context of all the policy
issues that are coming
everything from the DMP you have the DMP
tool to open data policies etc so as I
mentioned before the Big Data program
has focused both on foundational
research and on innovative applications
so it's just a question of the dial the
foundational research in both cases you
are looking for an application that
motivates the research but in
foundational you are really pushing some
new techniques and technologies again
whether it's CS statistics or math in
innovative applications we are looking
for something new being done in the
science but also using some innovative
techniques with the data and as I
mentioned over far is a participant all
of this by the way got started with the
announcement by the Obama administration
for the big data are in the initiative
which was in 2012 I think so 2013 was
the first set of awards when NSF and NIH
we're together at that time in the
program and that's just a breakdown of
so the big the colors I can I think you
can sort of see there's purple on one
side that's all the proposals that we're
focusing on data collection management
mining and machine learning the darker
one is health and bioinformatics and
then there are other disciplines other
focus areas like social networks
physical science engineering foundations
and CI 2014 we had a slightly different
categorization there's four categories
data and knowledge analytics data and
knowledge management computational
scientific discovery and innovative
applications and you see the breakdown
there there were 35 projects funded in
the most recent one that's just come out
and you can go to Fastlane and search
and look for big data in the current
awards we funded 42 proposals which are
30 different projects and that's because
several of them are collaborative across
multiple universities most of them are
actually collaborative at least within
the same campus
okay and here's the breakdown
sixty-three percent we're in the
foundational side 24 twenty percent on
the innovative applications in seventeen
percent were a combination of the two
and when I say foundational again it's
computer science statistics and math so
stats and maths Directorate is a
participant in the Big Data program and
there were six eager grants that were
also funded as part of this alright so
the hubsan spokes that's a new program
and based the basic idea here I won't
belabor all the details but the basic
idea is that we see an opportunity I
think at the end of the day we are
trying to push towards how to a bring
more data out and make it available for
the community to use for in their
research and be how to do this by
creating multi-sector partnerships okay
so the way it the way the program ended
up is that we have this notion of hubs
which are these coordinating groups that
are meant to coordinate within regions
and actually something interest we had a
series of meetings to plan this program
and something very interesting came up
in these meetings we each the meetings
were in each of the regions so we have
the West Northeast Midwest and south
these are the four regions and when we
had these meetings there were a lot of
universities from those regions as well
as industry a lot of the discussion was
about how these people were coming
together for the first time and one of
the things we asked in these meetings
just ask people to put up what resources
do they have available and all of a
sudden the university started saying oh
really you guys have these data we
didn't even know that you had that and
you know industry was talking about what
kind of requirements they have and the
universities hadn't heard from the local
industry so there's actually an
interesting sort of synergy beginning to
happen within the regions and I'm
actually very hopeful that this is going
to be a very interesting mechanism by
which new ideas will come forward and
new collaborations will come
forward one of the things we are looking
for the hubs to do actually the next
program logically after the hub's is
called the spokes and right now we are
working on the solicitation for that we
expect in a month or so maybe a couple
of months the solicitation will come out
as I mentioned the hub's were meant to
be this very high-level coordinating
activities in a region the spokes are
meant to have similar kind of diversity
of participation but focus on specific
technical areas so when the hub's got
together there were a lot of different
themes that came up that they identified
one theme that seems to be common across
the whole country is urban science and
smart cities okay so many regions are
interested in issues related to smart
cities another is global climate change
and for example in the West water was a
big issue so climate change and water in
the Midwest managing the freshwater in
the Great Lakes was a big issue so there
are some common themes of this time and
of course personal health was an issue
for everybody okay so what we want the
spokes to do then is to zoom in to
specific areas of that type and the
spokes will be affiliated with the hub's
but they can have membership from across
the country they don't have to be all
members within the particular region so
that's the next solicitation that's
going to be coming out so the idea of
the hub's is basically to initiate
partnerships identify what might be
common resources in the region so maybe
you have a supercomputer center or
storage facility here maybe there's a
university down the street that would
like to use it but they have something
else so form these kind of
collaborations access to the talent both
on the technology side and the science
side and then share best practices so as
I said one of the things we'd like these
hubs to do is to start identifying data
sets that may be available and and
expose this data again you already heard
about something like the NCI Commons
which which in a way is actually doing
for cancer data but and I think Bob did
mention it so as you start doing this
you start running into this issue of
api's and standards because I want to
share this data with that guy and so
what are the standard things by which we
can do this NSF has funded an activity
called RDA the research data Alliance
which is trying to do some of these
kinds of standards development and so we
like the hub's to play a role in not
only just trying to identify the data
but also trying to identify along what
standards can these be made available
and by doing this in all but the region
we hopefully reduce the cost of to
reduce some of the duplication that that
happens in these things so we had these
regional meetings as I mentioned the
Midwest folks this was several months
ago they met in ann arbor the west folks
actually met in Salt Lake City the
Northeast meeting was in Boston but I
think there's a group at NYU there was
trying to put together the northeast hub
these awards have been announced but
they're not of I think you can find them
on fast lane but they are not yet
officially announced and the south is
the meeting was in North Carolina and
Wren see which is University of North
Carolina Chapel Hill and judge a tech
we're involved with that I already
mentioned this these are some of the
topics that came up in the different
hubs and what we found is it's
interesting some topics are very of
interest to specific regions there are
others that cut across the whole and all
four sectors so some quick updates and I
should be done after that so there let
me talk about some recent up and
upcoming activities there is a fifth
meeting of all the hubs so this would be
all the funded folks will be getting
together from number third to fifth in
DC right after that another initiative
this actually also comes out of the
White House is trying to bring again
this is all in the vein of
trying to not only connect data
scientists with data but also trying to
get more data out so that people have
access to these assets that they can do
their research one way we want to do
this is through a meet-up of meetup
groups so there are many data science
meetup groups around the country know
there's a data science meetup group in
San Francisco that has a membership of
8,000 there's one in Boston this new
york city atlanta and each of the
smallest is to 3,000 members so if you
put all of these folks together you're
talking about something like thirty
forty thousand membership of people who
are saying they're interested in data
science a lot of these people are folks
who work in industry and they want to
just do data science problems as
something that's of out of interest okay
so we are bringing together the
coordinators of all of these meetup
groups together in DC and that's going
to be right after the hub's meeting so
we're trying to connect the hub's folks
to the meetup group folks so that you
the hubs get to meet all the meetup
groups that are in their regions and
that's another way to try and amplify
the message the big data p a program
itself will have a p.i meeting in
February a big area that is it's already
there but it's definitely looming in the
future is Internet of Things so you
expect most of the data that's going to
be coming in the future is going to be
coming from all of these devices whether
they're in factories or in your house or
on your body or in your car etc right so
we have started a series of workshops
just focused on the data problem with
the internet thing so there are a lot of
issues with IOT if you just do a search
on ID you see you know maybe hundreds of
meetings and conferences a lot of the
issues are at the device level at the
networking level security privacy etc we
are interested on just it's almost like
the theory of data in the Internet of
Things one of the issues for example is
the latency of data so if you have an
Internet of Things data is coming at you
at different rates for various reasons
the network's Layton sees there
part of the network may be down you
might be getting good data you might be
getting bad data but whatever
applications are running on top of that
they have to make decisions and they
have to do things at maybe a time you
know within some time frame so there's
issue of how do you build those kind of
systems and make those decisions in the
presence of all sorts of latency issues
and end data issues so we're trying to
focus on that we had one meeting on the
industrial internet and that was at
Cisco hosted by Cisco in san jose and we
are planning to have a couple more one
on smart and connected communities and
we are thinking Chicago might be the
place and we've actually talked with the
folks who do the internet array of
things Charlie Catlett and then of
course personalized medicine data
science and education i said i was going
to say something about that so that's a
big big deal and and i don't know if
this is happening at Yale but many
campuses are some of them already have
rolled out data science programs and
many are talking about doing data
science programs right so we had one
data science education workshop recently
at the University of Washington which
was really exciting there I the model of
that workshop was we funded was about
100 different graduate students from
different disciplines in fact it was
everything from humanities and one of
them was an artist who does data-based
art you know and outside hard sculptures
and things like this all the way to your
usual physical science type folks the
whole whole range and it was really
interesting to see the dynamics among
the students so just get grad students
coming together and all realizing that
you know they're all doing stuff with
data and many of them may be using
techniques that others could be you know
that you could learn from what the
others are doing so it's a little bit
like what sort of happens here except we
have hundred grad students from all over
the country from different schools so
that is a very interesting activity and
we are planning to I think we
continue that as an annual activity
another workshop the damn plan and I'm
planning and we have multiple folks at
NSF involved the education Directorate
the statistics for social science
computer science and also NIH is what
I'm we are calling as envisioning the
data science discipline so if you step
back and think about data so what's
happening right now and a lot of
campuses is people see a market
opportunity there's clearly a need to
produce students with a certain set of
skills and so they're trying to connect
the dots they are trying to connect the
dots from okay we have these kinds of
skills on campus we have a computer
science department we have stats we have
management and we want to produce you
know these kind of students so how do I
make progress which is we just fine it's
a very pragmatic way to put together a
data science program I think we are
saying we're trying to say something
different with this envisioning workshop
we're trying to say okay if data science
was a discipline what would it actually
look like okay and what would be the
fundamentals of data science that make
it different than computer science and
statistics etc it's undoubtedly an
intersection of computer science
statistics and social science but it's
more of a visioning exercise and I know
from that other things may flow other
workshops may happen etcetera and we
have requested the national academy of
science to run this workshop so that's
coming up if you have thoughts or
interests let me know we already have
some list of folks that we'd like to
invite to this and as you may or may not
know that every Directorate at NSF has
an advisory committee which is
essentially the folks from the community
who provide advice to the Directorate at
NSF and the size has an advisory
committee and we just now set up a
subcommittee of that focused on data
science education and so again they are
also looking at you know more from a
computer science point of view what
should we be doing what should we be
teaching what are the facilities that
need to be in place
to teach data science effectively and so
on last couple of slides so I did say
that there is interagency activity going
on so one of my jobs at NSF is to
actually co-chair this interagency group
which is called the Big Data senior
steering group which was actually set up
as part of the original Obama
administration initiative the group is
co-chaired by an NSF and NIH so it
includes over 18 different federal rd
agencies who are all interested in big
data so it's the usual we have NASA NOAA
DOD do e Department of Energy NSA and a
bunch of and NIST and so on there is
also so I'm just these are just
informational so that's going on and
actually we have weekly meeting or
monthly meetings thank God and we
actually invite external speakers to
come and speak and I think there's an
invitation out to Bob and the NOAA folks
to come and talk about the Nova cloud
that they went through another activity
going on is the NIST public working
group on big data which is actually
trying to develop standards and actually
I was a co-chair of that I have to say
I'm a non-active co-chair right now I
think one of the things that happens in
government is once your name is there it
is actually hard to remove it but it's
been interesting to observe that because
the field is moving so fast that every
time they get down to defining something
thus Moodle on and they're keeping up is
very hard maybe I won't sit too much
more about all this given the lateness
of the day so we do collaborate with NIH
there is a program we recently that NSF
recently announced with the statistics
division and NIH called quantitative
approaches to biomedical big data is
anyone from Yale participate in that you
know okay they have funded some number
of planning grants I believe and this is
again NIH interested in connecting with
the statistics community to see what
kind of statistical methods could be
used for the kind
of big data that they have in
biomedicine and I was mentioning earlier
to someone earlier today in fact had a
meeting with NIH Phil Bourne was just
speaker last year Phil and I have been
talking along with some folks at NSF
about doing a workshop and this one will
be in conjunction with the UK Research
Council's on how to try and expose more
biomedical data for the community to do
research on and so UK folks have you no
good data sets I think because of their
national health service and so on
increasingly NIH is trying to put out
more data sets there's something called
health data gov you might be familiar
with where us got you know agencies are
trying to publish health data and so
it's going to be an nsf-funded workshop
we will actually run it at NIH and we'll
have participation from the UK Research
Council's on that so my last slide is
some sort of things where we need your
inputs so this I think is a real
challenge how do we get our hands on
data okay so we need your ideas we need
to release more data we need to put it
out there and it's as you know it's not
just I mean the data has to sit next to
computing right so it's so it could be a
Hadoop style or whatever the style of
platform is but computing has to be
there with the data so it's not just
publishing files on an FTP site or
something like this how do we build
platforms at scale as I said I've
actually started a conversation with
some of the folks in the community and
this is more the computer science folks
so how would how would we do this right
and especially we're in an environment
where and as far as I'm concerned the
country doesn't care for R&B right if
you sit at NSF are somebody told said
the other day in fact our assistant
director said a flat is the new
positive or something that enough if
you're flat you'd be happy if your
budgets are flat usually it's supposed
to be happy and our budgets are flat
okay and I was at this workshop with
University of Washington one of the
faculty thing is it you know NSF doesn't
understand that there is inflation in
this world and by the way I was a p.i
till a year ago I was on the same inside
a year ago it's thought that NSF doesn't
at this head and itself budgets are flat
you know if you guys keep getting two or
three percent raises or you in higher
private schools probably give you lots
of big ray and as University of
California doesn't you huge raises sorry
that means you know you're going to put
less effort on a on a project because
the amount of money is fixed so if you
want to fix that I think you need to go
and talk to people in Washington DC so
that's my pitch to okay so we are in the
day of flat budgets but we want to have
these new initiatives now we want to
create new big data platforms in I mean
you can imagine back to the day 20 30
years ago when somebody said and this
was said Karen and Larry Smarr that we
need supercomputers we need super
computer centers and new money
materialized at NSF to fund
supercomputers okay this is what we need
today you know we need big data
platforms but how do we make it happen
so we need your help another issue and I
think some of you may be interested but
there I know there are other research
folks very much in this area of data
ownership you know who owns the data
including in today's well what's
happening to all of us right now
somebody again Bob all these references
are going back to Bob I think you
mentioned something about do you know
where your data is so there's this issue
of know how do we tackle that problem
right it's not it's not just the issue
of keeping data anonymized and private
and giving protected access but it's
also who who's the controlling power you
know who's who's ruling in this case and
the last thing I would say we actually
fund a group
and it's a new--it's a multi-campus
multi university but I think based out
of NY you and the other folks there's
folks from UC Irvine maybe Johns Hopkins
I can't remember all the schools i can't
remember VL is in it on it but it's
called big data ethics and society so i
read i talked about data science
education i mean i really think the data
data science has three legs its computer
science statistics and social science
especially the ethics part the biggest
Achilles heel for data science is going
to be on the ethics side because the
first time somebody I'm not that is
already not as not happened already but
you know the first time someone goes and
messes up your data it's going to be a
huge huge issue so we I think of ethics
as a very big topic and so again
whatever ideas you have the more you can
teach it the more you can do in it it's
great as I said we fund this group
called big data ethics in society and I
we've asked them to come and present at
the Big Data pais meeting we may also
ask them to attend the hub's meeting so
that they can sort of spray it's a very
good group of folks and so hopefully
they can spread this message so if you
have folks on this campus interested in
the ethics issue I think they should
really get connected to this so i
apologize for such a dry talk i didn't
realize it's going to be destroyed but
it's very interesting to me
too late in the afternoon for any such
thing so I also did not find that dry at
all I found it very interesting thank
you so Yael is actually a part of the
Northeast Regional big data hub right
along with Columbia and we currently
have three faculty that are helping
drive that initiative can you speak a
little bit about the skill sets for the
other folks that will be needed to help
support and propel that initiative
should the funding be received okay so
that's a very good question because I
think I had at the bottom of that slide
something about the hubs that tried are
there to enable you to do something that
you couldn't otherwise do by yourself
that is right and by when I say you it's
yoona campus well you know so it's
really regional in that sense so if you
I'm not sure what all the issues here
are but I know about water in San Diego
so let me pick water in California is an
issue so if you want to try and address
the water issue in California it's just
you know you need partnerships across
the state both in academia and also
agencies so I think the kind of folks
you need to be involved the hub's
program is very different than what NSF
has done before it's almost like an
altruistic well it's an organizational
thing but it's also altruistic soapy
eyes are not very good at being
altruistic right i mean i've been a p.i
so nopee eyes are all about okay what's
in the budget for me right but here we
are talking about how do you bring
together all sorts of different actors
to create a more complete picture of
whatever it is that you're trying to
solve so if you can get faculty who are
involved who are interested in that
another way to say
well one of the things I find especially
in the interdisciplinary work including
miles I've met some recent young faculty
at UCSD is that the young faculty have a
lot of energy in this interdisciplinary
stuff but i'm not sure if hubs is where
you want to engage them it if you can
find that senior faculty maybe bob but
bob is not so senior but you know if you
can find the experienced faculty who is
also interested in sort of doing
something that's broader than just their
own program those would be the right
kind of people and and certainly it
helps I mean obviously that means they
have to have an interest that's you know
we are using and you'll see it in the
solicitation as well we use these the
term national priority areas right so
the US government White House OSTP has
announced a number of priority areas
precision medicine is one global climate
change is one smart manufacturing smart
and connected communities these are all
considered to be priority areas so if
you have folks who are interested in
working in those priority areas but not
so narrowly interested in just their own
lab but actually trying to reach out and
help and and there are I'm sure there
are many here I certainly know folks at
other places where like that those would
be the best folks to engage this model
being extended to other parts of the
world oh good question so actually in
the spokes solicitation which we are
right now working on putting it together
we received interest from international
groups who want to participate in this
so the spokes the hub's didn't say it
but the spokes will actually say that we
encourage international partnerships and
so there could be some topics actually
smart cities is a good one right because
there's a faculty member at I think MIT
who may see ya she she visited Singapore
Singapore has a big smart city
initiative and what they realized is
because of the way everything gets
controlled in Singapore I suppose they
can control how how data is released and
they realize that the data that they
have is actually an asset for
international collaborations because not
many cities or states have that kind of
data that they have access to so for
example in smart and connected things
you say we have a connection with
Singapore and we can get all their data
and we can do some very fancy you know
parking optimization or whatever yeah
that that would be interesting so I
think the spokes will will ask for will
encourage international partnerships we
are also finding a lot of interest from
other agencies I'm not sure if the
solicitation will say it or not but some
of the agencies are even saying that
they may do their own solicitation which
in some ways is actually simpler but
then connect to the hubs so you know DHS
is also very interested in Smart City
issues and actually I mentioned the
Internet of Things workshop i don't
think i mentioned that the next series
of workshops we are doing is with DHS so
it will be NSF DHS jointly doing iot
workshops i wouldn't be surprised if
someone like that will put put something
out and say you know we have if we have
an opportunity here and we would like to
connect this to the NSF Hobbs
thank you for talk something you said I
thought was interesting or it was on
your side is that you said data is the
new instrument and I'm going from a
bioinformatics background and when I
think of bioinformatics compared to a
traditional life sciences I think of
instead of studying living things I'm
studying the data right I'm observing
the data and metadata on the data but I
usually think of the instruments that
I'm using as mathematics statistics in
computer science so as wonder if you
could talk a little bit about how you
see data as the actual instrument
instead of the thing being measured
right and you know and that's I think
what I really mean there is without
there's a lot of opportunity and I think
in astronomy this has already been done
where you can discover new things just
by analyzing the data so you don't have
to go to the instrument like a telescope
or something of course somebody went and
brought it together or the instrument I
mean other data could just be click
streams and maybe you observe some
social phenomena by observing something
in the clickstream that's kind of what I
mean so it's an instrument to study a
phenomena in that sense yeah
you
you